vous êtes battus mais qu'ils nous
entendent bien satisfait oui
déjà qu'on se bat c'est que jen
satisfaction d'avoir peut assumer les
engagements auxquels on en croit après
satisfait oui parce que quand même le
front le score du front national
quand même très important en progression
par rapport aux cantonales de 2011 et au
deuxième tour si vous voulez ça a été
maintenue même avec plus de voix même si
le pourcentage est un peu plus faible
donc ça veut dire qu'il y en ait un
électorat que bien sûr je remercie et
qui est assez fidèle et qui maintient
ses idées mais c'est surtout un
électorat si vous êtes conviction plus
qu'uniquement de la contestation de
conviction alors oui je pense qu'on peut
pas arriver un score il comme celui ci
parce que si en fait c'était que la
contestation
on devrait faire 90 % donc vous avez le
sentiment vous ancrer durablement dans
ce terrible je pense qu'on va commencer
à s'ancrer c'est vrai qu'on a à faire si
vous voulez à des notables entre
guillemets qui ont pris racine depuis 10
ans 20 ans 30 ans dont qu'ils ont
effectivement mal maîtrise du terrain le
relationnel client élise dans le bon
sens du terme
donc c'est quand même pas facile sur des
élections locales si vous voulez
d'arrivée et puis de bousculer un peu
tout le monde
ceci dit on a quand même bousculé parce
qu'on n'a pas fait des scores quand même
inintéressant ils sont quand même assez
conséquent et même je pense qu'elle a
beaucoup qui s'interroge un petit peu de
cette progression pas alors cependant
mise à part visiblement dans notre
canton les scores du front national dont
n'évolue guère finalement on a
l'impression en nombre de voix par
rapport au premier tour où est ce que
vous n'avez pas atteindre notre capacité
maximale insistons sur sur une semaine
c'est sûr que c'est pas facile de
doubler sa capacité
je crois les autres candidats ils n'ont
pas non plus fait des scores
pharaoniques en progression si vous
voulez après on sait très bien que
mettre dans les choses se sont inversées
c'est le premier tour où les électeurs
font le choix et le deuxième tour où il
élimine alors que par le passé c'était
un peu le contraire là maintenant on a
vraiment une vue assez précise et de
l'électorat sur le premier tour et
deuxième tours là quand même pour fear
mais voilà il y aura pas de conseiller
départemental en votant oui alors bien
sûr il y en a pas mais on savait très
bien que ce serait difficile si vous
voulez les temps impartis seul sans
alliance de pouvoir faire nécessairement
beaucoup de 50%
c'est encore un peu prématuré si vous
voulez donc ça c'est pas une déception
mais par contre on est quand même en
progression si ou lé olemps de voix